se tivéssemos todos em casa agora
totalmente esquecidos esta imagem é a
primeira coisa que faremos essa guerra
no comando da televisão e mudar o canal
ou então aproveitar o intervalo para nos
levantarmos de qualquer coisa o enviar
uma mensagem para outros é pô fazer
qualquer outra coisa do que ver um
anúncio porque as pessoas não vêem ou
não lei anúncios não é ninguém ligar a
televisão para ver é o último a campanha
do hipermercado a ninguém abre uma
conquista pra valer 11 núncio roger
as pessoas lêem apenas aquilo veio
apenas aquilo que lhe interessa o que
acontece é que por vezes esse conteúdo
que chamou nossa atenção é muitas vezes
um anúncio
e como é que quem disse é esta frase foi
a 1.13 citaram muito famoso da por volta
de 40 anos atrás disse esta frase que eu
tinha não sentiu que tinha uma mensagem
de voz publicitários na altura criam que
sem os seus anúncios e criar mensagens
interessantes que se relacionar com os
consumidores
o seu público alvo só assim desta forma
conseguiu chamar a sua atenção
e como é que iriam fazer isto é bom seja
criar uma campanha é o lançamento do
automóvel ou seja pra criar uma campanha
de prevenção do cancro da mama não é
publicidade apoiadas na sua ferramenta
mais poderosa que a criatividade ea e
muitas definições para a criatividade
não é por estar aqui a falar de várias
eu gosto particularmente de uma ferida
por vários artistas e inventores que
basicamente disse que a criatividade ea
habilidade ligar pontos que outros não
pensariam em ligar é por exemplo a
informação por exemplo de um produto e
ligamos conseguimos detectar os
expectativas no nas pessoas e ligamos
essas informações e expectativas e
transformamos numa mensagem que se
relaciona de alguma forma com o com as
pessoas e com shows dos anjos ser pegar
coisas que aparentemente a partida não
nos faria a ligação possível frontera
neste anúncio como uma marca de comida
que lhes que até podiam ser muito ter a
cara dos seus olhos e muito parecidos
com os seus olhos mas não creio que não
quer dizer que tenham comer a comida dos
dons para o argumento utilizado por esta
marca pra mostrar que os donos num e fmi
vão oferecer em uma pilha de que é
específica adotarem e esta ligação que
de fato de informações e forma com que
são trabalhadas que que horas depois a
idéias poderosas como estas em que neste
caso por exemplo é onde todos calharam
viam apenas mandaram os críticos
responsáveis por esta campanha é vira um
véu islâmico e uma forma de transmitir
é uma ideia no sentido de mostrar ao e
combater a discriminação religiosa mas
como é que como é que foi possível
chegar aqui o resultado é essa são as
avarias etapas já cumpridas
montamos centazzi não somos iluminados
do nada será todo um processo a todas
uma a todos um a uma série de etapas pra
pra pescar aqui o resultado
e pra falar neste neste processo é chava
que a pena também falar neste aqui é
bill berna que também publicitário
americano que na década de 60 e 70
revolucionou a publicidade e é hoje
considerado o pai da publicidade moderna
portanto descritivos hoje acho que é
geral a opinião tem que agradecer a
ouvir o barulho porque criou a base da
publicidade nos dias de hoje até a o
crescimento menor não era vista como uma
ciência que se acreditava se que havia
regras que se viu para tudo que era
anúncio esse resultado o papão no fim
posou está também o lançamento de um
carro e eu não concordava achava que
tinha que ver uma personalização tinha
que ver toda uma liminar as regras para
conseguir se conseguirmos construir
várias formas
as informações e criaram anúncios que só
resultassem para 1 para terminar produto
e é um exercício que ainda hoje fazemos
quando temos idéia é termos uma idéia e
e quando chegamos quando sentimos que
estamos lá uma das primeiras coisas que
estamos a cair sexta esta não se só é
bom serviço especificamente para esse
produto por este serviço servir para
outros é porque
num não é suficientemente bom e é o pior
é que o luciano também é publicidade no
sentido em que o rio organizou a forma
como é a equipa criativa trabalhava até
o crescimento eo processo começava com
joão pulido clientes entregavam
influiria era passado um briefing com os
objetivos do da campanha e do ator havia
um reator 1 copyright querem que é criar
os testes para vender determinado
produto seu importante pegavam os seus
testes sair outra sala às vezes até a
outro piso entregava o essa informação
um visualizador com o já conhecido como
diretor dava uma cara tava um grafismo a
campanha e agora que acreditava que
conseguia tirar muito mais potencial a
da criatividade
vamos juntar essas duas pessoas e e a
partir daí começou a trabalhar em dupla
e ainda hoje a agência volta do mundo
trabalham com com esta organização temos
um condutor que o responsável máximo
pela atualização dos testes e tem
diretor do visualizador que quem não é
correcto pôr pra dar uma cara à campanha
não quer dizer que o relator não não
sugiro uma imagem não quer dizer que o
visor também não tem é uma uma ideia
para o uma frase que vai definir a
campanha eleitoral outra outra outra
coisa que uma com muito é nesta altura e
que fez concluiu da infância considerado
pai da publicidade moderna foi é e eu
acreditava com os bônus tirado os
anúncios eram muito importante hoje em
dia se olhava continua a fazer algo que
fazia nuno antes pelo guarda que era uma
hiper mobilização do
da mensagem e que por vezes num retirar
esse caráter genuína mesmo e eu
acreditava também que uma grande
campanha num não é necessariamente uma
condição para o processo por exemplo do
o temos uma uma grande campanha uma
grande campanha não pode salvar uma
produto pronto quanto muito vai explorar
o seu declínio vai fazer a coisa não
bate certo que existe tem que ser tem
que ser genuína tentado acordo com o
produto
mentira no nos leva muito longe mas
voltando ao processo criativo
há pessoas que pensam que os críticos
têm uma vida muito baixada e brincar
áreas e com muitas festas pelo maio mas
a verdade é que num não existe ninguém
fica sentado ou deitado à espera de ter
um momento eureka da mesma forma que
charles darwin em breve quem acreditasse
que desagradaram tinha tido uma definida
enquanto lia um livro e se casaram que o
livro thomas malthus o autor da teoria
que explica o crescimento exponencial da
população e e que eu enquanto lê um
livro lembrou se que o homem poderia ser
um evento muito distante do móvel mas
pronto não foi assim
nota ou ficar essa investigação
o curso de charles darwin e até chegar à
ideia e scarpa e percebidos pelas notas
deixadas pelo pelos alunos da em que
esta teoria já estava a ser desenvolvida
a 10 dos mesmos foi preciso tempo foram
precisos cumprir é etapas para que
chegassem a esta população
mas como é que se chama como é que chega
esta etapa vai ser mesmo resultado
eu vou eu em ação para trás é é
existem várias técnicas de explicar o
processo criativo e que serve para
várias áreas só a aba eu vou usar uma
série de etapas que quer dizer isto nós
não temos presentes no dia a dia no
nosso dia a dia e às vezes é consciente
às vezes em coxim
mas eu vou utilizar uma série de etapas
só explicar que o curso do do processo
que ficou é que tem que dar é e como é
com menina então começa com uma emissão
ó eu fui chamado absorção em que
recebido o pedido do cliente recebidas
assim as informações todas relacionadas
com o produto
nós temos que construir nada nas
esponjas e absorver o máximo de
informação para para dar seguimento ao
processo
sexy edição o pinpoo que é quando e
compilada ea sua vida toda essa
informação a equipa criativa juntas para
bater umas bolas sobre sobre o assunto e
com base na informação que compilaram e
é que começa a brincar dar à
experimentação começamos a testar
possibilidades é é gerar o máximo de
combinações para conseguir gerado a
começar a gerar própria mente a idéia e
eu queria fazer uma uma comparação que
as duas críticas muitas vezes dentro do
mais são os incorporados como com com os
casais e as surfistas como como um filho
não é e por isso eles avisaram só vai
usar o meu filho para mostrar como é que
este é o início da edição o foco
naqueles não se envolve com uma primeira
ideia que o vasco simboliza vai
simbolizar a ideia começa com uma
primeira e normalmente nós confiamos em
tempo e em outras áreas acontece o mesmo
com fins sempre a primeira é por isso é
preciso aprofundar é preciso cavalo e
continuar a gerar idéias dos anjos mais
variados imaginava chegando este ponto e
tendo já sido uma boa
sai 110 pode ser cada um tem o seu
método mas quando os contos consegue
conhecer um bom número de idéias e
sentimos confiança na nos mesmos e
sentimos quando o pedido do cliente
o que acontece é que nós arriscamos e
vamos falar com o nosso diretor criativo
e apresentamos as idéias se porventura
correr tudo bem o que o cliente o
detective aprovado aí nós construímos a
campanha pelo instrumento apresentar aos
clientes o diretor criativo aprovado
então em entramos podemos continuamos a
trabalhar e e poupamos o risco de entrar
às vezes uma farsa e que chama de velho
estou completamente perdida que é um
ponto que nós apuramos o de todos os
anos e mais alguns e por vezes começam a
surgir idéias de seguirem estranhas que
não fazem muito sentido de que
dificilmente vou responder ao pedido do
cliente
então aí o melhor é desligar e entramos
na fase de incubação
hoje estação que é normal nesta fase em
que os críticos desligam e com base na
informação que compilaram com base de
todas as idéias que tiveram até a altura
do chão que o subconsciente de de forma
que permita desenvolver essas idéias
dentro deus
da mesma forma que as obras darão também
teve esse período está salva durante 10
dos meses é é da teoria da evolução
através da seleção natural das espécies
é também teve que ser durante muito
tempo muito dele e depois comentem que
obteve o terravista que é o final da da
espanha quando sentimos que chegamos ou
ao território vai conseguir responder à
o problema de comunicação determinado
cliente
isso cria queria falar aqui uma campanha
é esta estas fases
[Música]
a idéia final não tem que
necessariamente ser obtido no final
deste processo pode ser em vários e o
povo falava da absorção e é quando já
aconteceu campanhas
a idéia da campanha surgiu logo no
lançamento nessa fase que é a fase em
que estamos a ver a informação então
estou a fazer perguntas muitas perguntas
e é um caso em que o que eu falo muitas
vezes até que os meus colegas que foi
uma campanha desenvolvida para para onde
reúne fama com cidade das campanhas mais
brilhantes sempre em que o objetivo era
comunicar uma nova geração de motores a
diesel e durante esse processo durante
essa absorção os descritivos foram
conhecer o engenheiro-chefe da onda que
desenvolver o motor e descobrir em
conversa com o que eu tinha um ódio as
mortas no torcedor a dsal porque achava
que era um mero todos e eficiente e
muito poluente e e perceberam que era é
que lógico que eu tinha por exemplo que
os motores foi isso que o moveu foi isso
que o fez fazer alguma coisa mudar
alguma coisa e nesse o conceito esta
campanha quer ou edson santos enfim já
distante e que serviu para explicar o
porquê dessa forma como a onda abordou o
problema começou a forma como onda
olhava progenitores e serviu e foi
dramatizado uma animação e com uma
música que toda a gente acaba por
baratear e também ao mesmo tempo aplicar
um lançamento do produto acabou por
inspirar as pessoas também a pensarem
nessas coisas como de avião nas suas
vidas só as obras as suas vidas
profissionais é poder quase servir como
um método não é em vez de estarmos a
criar resistências e quando escolhemos
com alguma coisa que estamos num tempo
de criar resistências temos sim arranjar
motivação para mudar
[Música]
essa coisa é neste caso aqui e nem em
uma fase posterior
já estamos na iluminação votando aqui a
fazer humilhação ou da terra à vista eu
e sukiyaki outro exemplo de uma uma
campanha da nike uma das ferramentas
campanhas móveis da anac e esta frase
aéreas farão as frases mais icônicas de
publicidade que o autor a gente se
lembra dela e que surgiu foi no momento
em um foi no início é na que estava
estava cheia e nintendo encomendou uma
campanha de publicidade para concretizar
esse crescimento
na altura e durante o processo de
criação 11 um dos criativos que as
idéias podem mexer em todo lado já estou
chegando
quer dizer vitória as pessoas tenham
ideias quando estavam a dormir pessoas
contavam com uma pane que o dia claro
que não foi do nada mais uma vez foi
porque já estavam a estudar já estava
grudado determinado problema e neste
caso enquanto estavam mergulhados no
problema ou um dos criativos que
enquanto lia um jornal
daniel é o pequeno almoço de pôr os com
a notícia de um preso que ia ser
executado nesta semana nos estados
unidos e vinha com uma declaração de
alguém dizia let's do it
e naquele momento e por mais estranho
que possa parecer o criativo é show que
estava ali a solução pra para a campanha
para o ponto de partida para pra uma das
campanhas mais
famosas da noite e que transformou no
lecs tweets no dia do evento
é é night quando confrontada com esta
história não confirma e por motivos
óbvios porque não ia tirar nenhum é esse
que atiraria é que ela é aquela mensagem
poderosa que está por trás do dia se
doente e que acabou quase para o
ultrapassar a publicidade susan sarandon
passaram a usar isso como filosofia de
vida pelos repentistas dissessem que
esta frase inicialmente investido de uma
declaração do meu só tem sido executada
talvez isso galera que vai agora com
essa imagem bonita que assistiram nesta
campanha
terminado esse processo de chegada é
muito importante às vezes e e achamos
ser o ponto de partida e na minha
opinião acho que eh eh um é o que define
mas as campanhas e é o momento mais
importante é quando se consegue
condensar numa frase tudo o que
determinada marca ou determinado produto
ou até uma pessoa que pretende comunicar
ao seu público e um exemplo dos gestores
é um dos mais famosos incluem frente da
apple é outro e outro exemplo muito
famoso tvi são feitas as dramatizações
atravessam são criados anúncios de
imprensa são criados filmes rádios tudo
mas tudo com esses que seguem essa
elemento unificador que é o conceito é
feito essa peça é transformar esta
dramatização dos
dodô com sete diferentes peças no
desfile nos diferentes meios de
comunicação é apresentada então a
proposta chega o momento da verdade em
que vamos apresentar a idéia o diretor
criativo que provar por vezes pode
acontecer é dizer e vai pensar mais um
que ele então voltamos uol 10 e
repetimos o processo mas tudo o que mais
lhe entregamos uma idéia como dj's
twitter
o mais provável é que o qual chora ao
ver e daí a prova embora ele e sexy
a criação da proposta para depois
apresentarmos o cliente está dentro da
normalidade o cliente vai chumbar a
proposta e nós vamos voltar a novamente
o início do processo mas não é sempre
assim mais uma vez contamos perante uma
má ideia vencedora e e quando estão
todos alinhados agência e clientes
a campanha aprovada e e passarmos a fase
da produção e é e não é neste ponto que
o processo criativo se esgota vai
envolver poxa com a colaboração de todo
tipo de pessoas contagiadas pela pela
idéia apresentada vão ajudar a
materializar aula vão aperfeiçoar vamos
torná-la maior do que ela realmente era
antes
por exemplo os criativos e criaram os
críticos como criar ela era grande mas
quando se materializa e quando não está
no meu feitio otimista e é muito
importante porque dizer não basta ter
uma grande idéia não basta apresentar e
e aprovaram uma grande idéia é este
momento também é decisivo para que essa
grande idéia seja visto como tal os
olhos do dos consumidores e está usando
uma criação do comportamento uma compra
por exemplo e é muito importante a
colaboração vai desde o todos são
importantes nesse processo não é idéia
não nasce da cabeça
a pessoa nasce dentro da agência do dedé
é um trabalho de equipa e é isso que faz
que cheiro é o próprio cliente também
ajudar a encher o realizador que o
responsável pelo filme também faz o
mesmo e todos eles se estruturam e
potenciam um é a idéia para que consiga
concretizar os objetivos e que seja
vista também como algo memorável dos
olhos dos consumidores é eu queria falar
tamanho agora por aí que só agora parece
que o tempo terminou mas eu vou falar
muito rapidamente
[Música]
este processo eo processo só para
mostrar tentar e estruturar o processo o
espaço é da idéia é regra às vezes é que
não há regras
a outra é a outra coisa que eu julgo que
é pra mim é no meu processo criativo e
que eu valorizo bastante e tento me
lembrar um centro brincar brincar e não
é brincar no sentido do não é da forma
menos chery não é não é tarefa não está
a desvalorizar o que o time alemão já no
sentido do descumprimento tarde com uma
criança faz quando está a brincar com o
colega estar possibilidade é ser curioso
continuar a ser curioso como também é
uma criança e por isso acho que é todos
nós não nos podemos esquecer isso
não se esqueçam brincar
obrigado
[Aplausos]